this is a production of Cornell
University
I just wanted to say it's a pleasure to
have this opportunity to introduce uh Dr
Raju Raja Guru buhar I've known him
since uh 2009 but I'm going to give you
a little bit of his background he has an
interesting CV he earned his bachelor's
his undergraduate in from Tamil Nadu
agricultural University in the southern
part of India in 2009 he had focused his
work on agricultural biotechnology and
he was studying the drebed genes in rice
for those of you who know those are
genes associated with drought response
and abiotic stress tolerance and rice
and then he continued his work at Tom at
Tamil Nadu at tnau and he earned a
master's degree that was done in
conjunction with um the Tata Cornell
program
he also focused on biotechnology but he
he combined that with business
management for his Masters and that
degree was from 2009 to 2011 but for the
2009 to 2010 year he came to Cornell as
an MPS student in plant breeding and did
his research in my lab so that's how I
got to know Raja Guru and I've seen him
many times since then including this one
time here I'm showing you a picture of
us at his home University in Tamil Nadu
in 2015.
anyway he went on he's he's had various
different types of employment he worked
in in Industry he worked for Rossi seeds
in India as a scientist in molecular
breeding he joined icarusat in 2018 I
believe he worked there for three years
when icarusat was at that time still
part of the CG and he was a project
coordinator for the high throughput
genotyping project
and there he was working across many
crops in fact I ran into him several
times at ikris during that time because
we were also he was also part of the
Gobi project
he then uh transitioned to Summit when
icarusat left the CG and he's still at
icarusat on campus but he works now
through the cement coordinated
headquarters he's the regional
genotyping coordinator for South Asia so
he's still in India but working for
cement he's a senior manager in the
cgiar Excellence in breeding program and
he helps to optimize the flow of samples
from breeding programs to genotyping
centers and back to breeding programs to
facilitate the routine implementation of
of genomic selection and um yeah
efficiency and breeding so you'll hear a
lot more about that work and I just want
to ask you to join me in welcoming Dr
buhar to give his seminar entitled
empowering cgiar Nars breeding networks
connecting the three dots of Discovery
validation and unparalleled Services
through cgiar BRS lab services for
Global access and impact
the stage is yours
okay first thanks star for giving me the
opportunity to present uh to my home
University students my experience with
this uh cjr and then several uh
functions within training network uh I I
feel very excited to be introduced by
Susan uh who was the I would say the
main pillar who brought me here uh
introducing me to the field of plant
breeding and then getting not only with
my graduate program even after that when
I joined the industry and still now in
various capacity I was getting the
guidance and support thank you so much
Susan for all your support so without
further delay I would like to get into
the seminar for one tough time so good
afternoon everyone I'm very pleased to
be present here and share some of my
experience Within Network
so don't be scared with the uh the big
title I'm not going to steal a lot of
time I'm just going to give you a
glimpse of what we are really doing with
uh connecting you know this discovery
validation and services for a CDR mass
network
okay so I just wanted to share some of
these pictures which I had
when I was compelling these pictures uh
I was taken back you know it was 15
years ago so it was in 2009 I had a good
experience when I was in corner uh you
know thanks to the entire you know my
teachers when I was there
especially Susan Mark Sorrell and
several other faculties who you know
introduced me to the field of plant
reading and how fascinating it would be
when we take a plant feeding field as
ever carrier so this first one is
uh you could see Mark standing over
there and in several of my classmates
they were you know either they were in
the seed industry Academia or CG as well
and then the next one I pulled out this
picture when we went to uh the Apple gem
plus and collection fee then this room
is with the bear and then the last one
with the Susan's lab so just to share
you know the wonderful time I had with
the corner University so this is also
you know because we are going to
start my slides with some challenges I
always wanted to start something
positive so I just put this slide as a
stuff holder
okay so before introducing to the
current work what I'm doing I just
wanted to uh introduce the connection
way we are here so as you all know this
graph would be very familiar to you seen
in many Publications and then talks
so you know the increase in populations
so with every year increase we have more
amount to feed as softly not 20 uh 120
or so uh it would be you know like
almost 10 million miles to field so
this is one side and then in terms of uh
under nourishment uh still you know you
could see a drastic reduction in the
percentage of undernourishment but it's
still in the higher side and then if you
see the predictions is that if we go
back to you know where we started in
2005.
so there are a number of ways to address
these challenges how you know like going
to tackle the Menace of climate change
the population Improvement the poverty
the undernourishment
but then uh plant breeding holds an
important role to address all these
concerns there are a lot of Technologies
and the Improvement and then modern
tools which enhance this process of
tackling these kind of challenges
especially in this population
Improvement and then climate change and
then under nourishment
I'm more going to focus on the molecular
breeding especially molecular markers
which is my area of expertise and then
where the Excellence in breeding I was
operating with them so there are a
number of uh you know
molecular tools including you know when
we started with Visa based marker to the
Next Generation sequencing
they address a similar kind of
challenges which is you know uh
increasing the efficiency of throttle
Improvement or product development uh
decreasing the time interval taken for
the product development
there are pros and cons when you see uh
in terms of comparison of different
molecular markers so you would really
appreciate why I am bringing all this uh
you know bits and pieces together
when we finish this seminar
and then when you talk about you know
the role of molecular markers uh I
wanted to give a little bit of glance on
this Genting game greatest equation
where how this molecular markers are
playing a critical role in increasing
genetic gains either in terms of you
know increasing the selection intensity
where the liquidity of molecular markers
improve this uh
a selection intensity to a high level
and then you know at some point uh
including the technology like speed
breeding to reduce the length of the
cycle interval thereby increasing the
Champions even for that matter you know
uh you need molecular tools for
selection
or to complement the speed reading
technology that way you can increase the
generic case so with this all note I'm
just going to jump in right away so the
current work what we are doing which is
connected with each of the of the slide
I would come back at the end of my
presentation how we are connected with
all this particular topics
okay so yes we understand there is a
population improved develop I mean uh
issue there was a climate change there
is a requirement of accelerated genetic
gain Improvement within the uh the
breeding program but uh not just with
the CG Center or the public leading
program we can tackle this issue so when
we wanted to connect to the end uh the
audience which is the farmers the
customers we need the support of uh Nas
program which is National agriculture
research extension program across
different countries
so realizing this very important aspect
that was a network of CG nurse now you
know sometimes they now called as CG
Nars SME Network
where you do not have this objective of
crop Improvement just in the perspective
of CG but as a network so we have a very
critical role of Nas and the different
public sector and private sector who
needs to be collectively work together
to achieve this you know uh genetic
gains Improvement which is very much
required to title the issue of climate
change population Improvement and
understand
why I am suddenly bringing this concept
is so if you see in terms of the the
access to the technology and then access
to the different tools not all this
breeding program has uh you know a
similar kind of access level
if you see the CG uh some CG centers
they may have their own in-house
facility
to do their you know either sequencing
or genotyping but if you take a small
breeding program or small uh even Mars
Network which is uh you know the end uh
stage where your product get delivered
to the audience they were not equally
get the opportunity to all these tools
and technology so this is the background
so how do you enable all these tools and
technology which will accelerate the
rate of genetic gains so I'm going to
specifically talk about how we achieved
uh passing this to the uh across CG
Mouse breeding Network in terms of
genotyping and other services which we
operate in the model of shared services
so that they do not know require this
facility to operate such answers so I'm
going to introduce to such models
so before getting into that I would like
to take a minute to introduce to CGR
Excellence including program where
currently I was belonging I was
currently working with
so the main objective of CGR excellence
in Reading Program is to modernize the
breeding program for higher rate of
genetic gains and married return over so
they mainly focus on product design and
management optimizing breeding uh tools
and Technologies for genotyping and
sequencing phenotyping and
bioinformatics and they have a Norse
module collectively uh the goal is to
modernize the operating program not only
with the CG Center and also for the
national network so uh
you most of you would have already know
about the development of one CGR
initiative where all the CG centers are
coming together under the single
umbrella so with that
EAB is transitioning into a new uh brand
called breeding resources so breeding
resources is one among the different
initiatives of one CJ yeah
where each of these modules has been you
know transitioned into a different
initiatives for example the genotyping
phenotyping and the uh why information
data analysis those kind of support
services
comes into the Brady resource module So
currently uh genotyping and sequencing
within eav is transitioned into the
breeding resources where we operate not
just as you know policy advisor but in
the institutional framework
so this particular slide which will help
you to understand where we we are in the
whole process of you know uh reading
process model if you take you know there
are several stakeholders and several
functions uh which is working together
to achieve you know the entire breathing
process models let it be the gene bank
or the product design trade Discovery so
these were different functions and then
there are set of functions like grading
analytics trading and Nursery lab
service processes
which were recording grading operation
processes which is a cut across
different functions so we are
let me just uh take the pointer
okay so we we are here when we say we
are the genotyping module where I
currently belong is placed in lab
service processes which takes care of
all the uh genotyping requirements if
there is a requirement of genotyping in
right Discovery and deployment we work
with them
there is a requirement of genotyping in
job plus and characterization Gene Bank
we work with them if there is a
genotypic requirement for adoption study
or DNA fingerprinting for varietal
identification when it goes for you know
uh scaling seed system we work with them
so in irrelevant of you know uh the
function wherever there is a requirement
of genotyping and then genomics tools uh
involvement so we work with them and
then we will Implement uh the the
required
tools and Technologies
so I would like to introduce some of the
genotypic services which are offered
through the Excellence in bidding and
currently with reading Research Services
so this was uh the the I would call it
as a product so we are operating more in
terms of business aspect it's not just
with service we connect with the uh
different stakeholders including the
Breeders the molecular scientists the
National Building program the cge
upgrading program through you know a
shared service principle where we have
an engagement with an external service
provider currently these services are
offered to internet so
the the way how we operate this so we
have this uh all these molecular markers
coming from different crop different
Institute we put together in a single
platform and then made accessible
through the external service provider
where any of the partner Institute let
it be the national program The
Universities the uh the uproad private
uh seed sector or small median
Enterprises uh the CG Pro up reading
program and different regions they can
just send their relief materials and get
it genotype for whatever the crops which
we are engaging with so this is a
publicly accessible documents and go to
this web link and then click any of this
icon of this craft which will give you
the uh you know the Excel sheet which
contain what are the genes and the types
the markers are available you can just
code the snip IDs and send your Leaf
material and get the data back at a very
competitive so this is so we operate we
negotiate with different vendors and
Scout for the right
service provider
and then we make this molecular tools
accessible between the service provider
for any of this breeding Network which I
mentioned so this is how we operate so
this started with this hydropogenotyping
project where I was working initially
with the CG and then that later
transition into EAB and now we rebranded
that as a low density genotyping uh so
where this is some Casp based chemistry
specifically focusing on trade-based uh
marker work like you know worker State
selection
and the later we realized there is a
requirement of quality control uh
parameter in reading program your F1
purity testing seed query then we know
concentrated on bringing the more
quality control markers for most of
these crops these QC markers are
currently available so for this low
density caspase testing
you can utilize for tribe waste
genotyping and also for QC
and then later we uh you know this was
maybe like from 2016 to 2018 19 or so we
slowly uh brought more crops into the
picture and then more uh you know
partners and service users and then I
could recollect you know we coordinate
almost like a two million dollar worth
of genotyping between 2016 to 2020
through the htpg project and then later
we understand there was a push for
genomic selection so that you know uh
the the products uh reaches the market
in a very short period of time and also
it has a great role in accelerating the
genetic game uh but the low density
Casper based markers were not so
sufficient to address that particular uh
uh you know GS
then we started working with the uh CG
molecular team and then uh scouted for
different technology which could address
uh to give the genotyping in terms of
thousand to five thousand marker density
which is required for the genomic
selection at a very cheaper cost we have
multiple options even currently now
either the chip genotyping different
sequencing technology which can give you
more marker density but then if you talk
about uh implementing that particular
methodology in the routine trading
program uh the the very essential factor
is the cost involve and the turnaround
effect so we keep these two factors very
particular and then offering these
mittens Regional taping in the range of
you know 12 to 13 dollars per sample
independent of whatever the market
density so these are the current marker
panels which is available through the
platform uh wherever you have this
hyperlink those were already implemented
I can just click and then see the
background how those markers were
developed for example I would take the
example of circle
uh almost like 800 to 1000 lines
sequenced data the uh chip data whatever
the sequence information and the snip
information those were collected and
then they came up with the you know
3500 markups or so which were put into
the dark Tech platform so this is a dark
tag custom amplicon sequencing
technology should not become confused
with the dot seek which may be you know
you get kind of random or a different
type of results this is a custom amplica
sequencing technology where you get you
know uh
and then the how we operated here is uh
instead of focusing just the CG program
or not reading program we uh targeted
the crop Network across different uh you
know regions for example for sorghum
when we started we invited
different audience like you know the
Invader cancer State we invented LC
Network we invited different National
programs working with surdham mrappa CG
of the community and then uh these
markers were showcased to them
whatever trades or markets which is
missing from this panel uh different
partner they have offered those markers
information and then uh it it is being
like a global panel which is being
utilized by different audience for
different purpose so this is how we
operate
and then we are also constantly
upgrading for example uh if you see you
know 2.0 which is uh we started with the
minimum set of marker initially and then
it has a flexibility to upgrade this
panel so I think for feature based we
have 2.4 which is the second version but
though we are currently working for the
second version
and then for Rice we have this 1K recap
panel through this platform there is a
ongoing process for improving the panel
for increased density 4K
we're also working for bringing up uh
four to five key haplo panel targeting
different hapload types for Rice
function engines and also trying to
apply the same model for bringing a
pathogen panel
for detecting the uh different pathogens
rice pathogens
uh by bringing uh
Target Snips for that particular you
know pathotypes uh are they also trying
to see if there is a possibility to
bring a multi-uh pathogen panel where uh
different Snips for different pathogen
of different crops can be combined in a
single panel so that uh the the
pathology uh
function can also utilize the similar
methodology so this is a nutshell about
the mid density panel this is also
publicly accessible document you can go
to through this link uh and then you
know see the background of how it was
developed and what purpose uh this panel
can be interested
so this is about low density Envy
density and then
during this process we realized you know
for many crops there was no proper
reference genome assembly is available
for instance they may come from a while
variety which is not so relevant with
the elite breeding material
so when they go for a market calling so
they face many challenges so through a
cth project and from the project so we
got uh you know a possibility to have a
new uh reference assembly for different
jobs so we scouted for the available
reference you know and then we we ran
through a process and figured out what
are the three crops which requires a new
reference you know and then we started
working with uh
yeah and then copy and so many other
props
and then uh most of the crops you know
those were under pipeline some of the
new reference were already
released through the uh with the CG data
portal you can you know access these
datas for the release to banana and then
plant the independent new reference
genome through this data project
along with that we are also constantly
working with different service providers
to provide a whole generic sequencing at
a very affordable cost if you see
different CTE
training programs you know for want of
uh characterization or Market Discovery
still there is a requirement of routine
resequencing in their work uh we see
there is a opportunity to bring that
cost down so we are working with the two
service provider to have a negotiated
pricing for most of these clubs so for
Rice we have piloted protection and the
results are coming good and then they
are also using that particular
snip data for development of new 4k
times
yeah so
as of now you could see you know a lot
of
services for genotyping and then
bringing the success story and then
experience with this you know providing
genotyping Services we realized the same
kind of model can be also applied for
other services
so we did the demand assessment what are
the services you know which is currently
uh required by the breeding program of
CG and nurse Partners where they face
either challenges or the cost is very
high because
we don't have a collective bargaining
process so in the genotyping services
the one particular thing which we have
tapped is the collective bargaining we
color we collate all the You Know sample
demand from different CG Center National
program across the globe
and then we negotiate with the service
provider with the collective bargaining
program where we were able to bring down
the cost and then you know a substantial
Direction in the uh the Eternal Trend
because you know we formalize and then
uh standardize lot of these Logistics
which is so much Essential for the
moment of sample from different regions
to the service provider
taking that experience we are piloting
for the nutritional testing
currently we are trying to have a
similar kind of model for uh Elemental
analysis of ions Inc and aluminum so we
are having uh agreement with Filter tech
for providing this analysis through icpu
is and also we are partnering with the
Harvest plus where the internal Labs
through Harvest was located a different
regions
the xrf and then uh facility can be
utilized for non-destructive analysis of
inrc why we started with iron and zinc
is as you all know we have into the
process of buyer fortification
the iron and zinc were
pioneered in terms of
mainstreaming this uh
nutrients into the the products so
either in the discovery process or in
the breeding program or in the product
level that is a routine made of testing
the iron engine
so we brought down the cost to a
substantial level and then the breeding
program started uh you know submitting
these samples for initial test
validations
um if you see
there are so many number of Partners and
so many number of stakeholders involved
in this process currently
everything uh you know happens to the
email communication we have an order
forms that must be filled and then
communicated to the AV coordinators we
check them and then communicate to the
vendors it's a long process and then
there is no
accountability or traceability of you
know all these orders imagine you know
18 plus crops in the different Services
different Mass partner different
countries
so these samples will go to you know any
of the three Labs located in Sweden
Australia and India for the low density
and then further to Dart in Australia
foreign and then if you see sequencing
either to the U.S or the Australia so
there are multiple regulation of You
Know sample moment involved so we
thought that's certain requirement of
developing a portal where we can manage
all these services so we launched this
uh platform called genotyping submission
portal you can register through this
link if you want to submit your samples
for lower one we density or for
nutritional testing also we are trying
to bring the similar kind of model
there is a pre-launch demo uh you can
see in YouTube watch how to access this
model why I brought this specifically to
the seminar is if some of the students
working with different crops find some
of these markers available from the
platform relevant with your current
project or in future with your breeding
process so you can access all these
Services through this one particular
platform where we will manage on the
back end for your answers to this uh
different services
okay so these are all the tools and
services we offer uh we also you know
constantly give a training and
backstopping uh we engage with different
new partners in Africa and South Asia
and Southeast Asia
we will work with them go to their field
and then train them in terms of sampling
in logistics and connect them with the
different analytics group for the data
analysis and so many other uh related
analysis Network so we help them in
terms of you know right from going to
the field collecting the sample
processing the sample
so we'll be always you know hand folding
them until their first data comes back
and then even after uh there they get
experience we always go you know
backstop with further follow-ups and
then helping them in terms of
implementing the uh
genomics into their relative degrees for
example
and then if you see
I'm just talking theoretically how this
is possible I'm talking about uh you
know like a model which is uh
implemented and then tested in different
crop different region and different
functions these were some of the you
know
example of some of the success stories
if you see a lot of Publications came up
uh we don't uh you know involved with uh
you know our names being included in the
publication I'm just showcasing this how
these services are you know applied in
either Discovery or implementation or
you could see a lot of you know
validation done for different traits and
then implemented through the platform
you can also see a lot of Publications
and success stories case studies
these particular
shared services being used to implement
lot of QPS and genes into the breeding
program so the way I see this is
there is no limitations for the breeding
program in irrelevant of where they are
coming from how because small their
breeding program or how big or small
they are installed so they have the
possibility to access all these tools
and Technologies through this platform
so this is the way I see how this is you
know being successful in different uh
you know crops and different Networks
I just wanted to spend a couple of
minutes uh you know explaining this one
so I just pulled out a different partner
networks uh who are involved in this in
this rice grading Network and then
protector Networks
to see the rice network if you see most
of the markets are coming from eating
but then if you see our uh you know user
database these are the some of the
Indian national Partners who are
constantly utilizing the city market to
the platform and then we also you know
opened up to to the small breeding
Network in the public the private sector
through the public private partnership
they can also you know utilize this uh
markers
but at the different pricing structure
which is now only applicable to be
non-profit they they have a different
pricing structure but they have the
access to this particular marker and
then the same markers are replacing
Bangladesh nurse very and then
Philippines nurse will rise and then if
you see uh the national Partners also
offering their tester markers through
this platform where you know recently we
got a DSR related marker from Pau
validated in their Institute they offer
through the platform which is successful
by the rest of the audience even within
CG the markers from media can be
utilized by the Africa race program or
CR program and Market from seat raise
program can be replaced by the rest of
the Nas and the Aryan album the same
thing you know talking about potato or
wheat the markers coming from CGS Center
how it can penetrated and be greatly
utilized by different National programs
so this is how I see uh you know the the
success of shared genotyping that the
production is ready validated markers
are not just restricted with the one
particular lab then coming to this
platform being widely adopted and then
you know
implemented into their team leading
operation
so we are very small team uh we have n
who started with this htpg and then the
module lead of EAB and also known BRS
and we have other colleagues based in
Nairobi taking care of Esa and then in
Africa is taking care of a WCA and I'm
sitting at the Hyderabad taking care of
South Asia and now more involved in
Southeast Asia as well
so you can contact any of us and we have
a general contact if you drop us a email
on any of these
request for either genotyping or
nutritional testing we'll be happily uh
addressing your uh
and I would uh like to tag all the
donors contributors vendors and services
this one particular picture we took
during the annual meeting together with
San Diego as a sideline meeting with
back you could see many of uh I think
Mark is here and then some other
Cardinal faculty and
meeting
and then this is our koti uh getting
this uh updating Research Services uh
this is a team with GSL erila uh I was
closely associated and
aligning diabeting process model in the
BRS model uh harmonizing the process so
this is a very small uh you know
contribution pictures but there are
still many of other contributors who
helped us to build this network offer
their markers services and then
constantly you know creating these
panels to be enabled to to not only to
the CG program but also to the rest of
the national partners and other public
trading brokers I also wanted to take
this opportunity to
attack the donors and also different
partner Institute who are constantly
engaging with us in adopting the
genotyping services for a very long days
so this is the end of the slide uh with
this I can thank you very much for
Patiently listening and be happy to
answer if you have any questions thank
you so much
yeah so for the people in the room and
also we have now 18 on the line uh feel
free uh to share comments and questions
about Raja group
go ahead yeah I'm curious what are some
of the biggest challenges you face
coordinating the processing of such a
huge volume of samples from so many
Geographic locations and also the
processing of data and the limit of the
data and acquiring kind of solutions
that you found in these challenges
can you hear the question okay
if you understand currently uh you will
ask me about the biggest challenge
faced in coordinating with such a wide
you know audience and the different
agents is that correct stuff that's
right yeah and also the volume of those
examples that you deal with from so many
different locations what are some of the
challenges that you faced and how you're
able to deal with
yeah so yeah that's a good questions you
know this uh biggest challenge we Face
uh you know the
to have a good quality data you should
have a good quality samples so if you
see you know some of the samples are
coming from the remote regions uh the
time taken uh to get those samples
delivered to you know uh different uh
Labs uh that's one big Challenge and
then the other one is the rules and
regulations uh different countries have
different schools and regulations in
terms of uh leave sample number DNA
sampling moment so we need to uh you
know sort out those issues
so these were some of the logistic
challenges and then the other thing is
different service user will be at a
different capacity to implement this
particular molecular aspect into the web
reading program so we need to assess
where they belong so it's not like uh
you know
uh we can directly Implement genomic
selection for a status so we sync with
them we understand there's a breeding
principles and then the status of the
embedding program and then slowly we
start with either you know genetic
characterization so assessing a
different audience that's being the
other channel so you know with the ears
passing way we are learning from past
experience and then transforming in
another way we happened along this issue
so we sort of uh we'll work on all those
issues in the past 12 years
thanks
on the line we have questions from
Bethany
National programs give me the minimum
sample number for the intertek data
contact how you develop a mechanisms to
help Small Program utilize these
services without having to pay an
increased price per sample due to their
smaller sample size
thank you
thanks Bethany so I think you know this
being a question for the floating around
from they're getting constantly these
questions in different audience but we
are constantly engaging with the vendors
I just wanted to you know pinpoint one
particular issue a technical uh
implementations with the lab where they
operate all these genotyping through the
liquid and device either with the 384 or
1536 you know uh modules so that's the
reason you know they are not able to
just stick with one or two nine six
plane because even with that they need
to spend all the consumables which you
are required for 384 being said that we
receive a similar kind of request from
different audience we are working out
some you know uh some ways to handle
that for example the negotiated with
event for instance but then you might be
already knowing after 384 if you submit
one more extra plate earlier it would be
count does the next batch of 384 and you
will be raised for eighth place now we
are negotiating after 384 the first
place may have you know just uh 30
percent more cost or so for a one single
player and not calculated in the basis
of all four uh 384 set for this one
aspect we are discussing uh for the
possible implementation but we are also
discussing with them how we can engage
in a different uh use of we could have
only 94 or 192 samples also the other
way how we are tackling is uh combining
samples from different uh programs which
have a similar uh genotypingies and then
assembling a 384 uh we could recollect
you know we did this for some of the uh
you know rice and then cassava program
and that combine the samples from
different areas so yeah I I think I can
explain it later as well some of our
future videos thank you
yeah so earlier before I call you like
room we have two more questions okay
yeah so you with your hand if you go for
it
oh you're clear or not okay someone else
I saw Ray's hand
no okay oh yeah
[Music]
um
small sample size
yeah for nutrition no analysis for the
sample non-destructive method is that
there is a problem if the sample size is
small
is that right
um
is there any problem encountered it is
formed
means
nutrition quality
could you give an example like say rice
like how many lives
provide the microphone
um
so if you are using non-destructive
methods of estimating the nutritional
quality or for that matter inequality
seed quality parameter uh if the sample
size is small will that be effective
enough or will it be a representative of
the whole seed lot
uh so we are just uh
uh you know starting that with nutrition
statement we just launched it uh we
still were you know figuring out the
validation process so we have our
knowledge partner Harvest plus uh who is
helping us with this nutritional
interesting uh I apologize I was not
very much expert in that field so maybe
I could uh you know uh link you with
that Harvest plus group so they will be
helping you you know in terms of if you
have any technical questions feel free
to reach out to me uh I'll be happy to
connect you with them thanks
yeah I think this is a statistical
sampling question maybe ask Kylie by
chance I also did my postdoc um see the
Green Quality analysis for soybean
definitely this will be a concern
especially in your packet in your bag
the seas are heterogeneous right so you
need to see it's a fixed line and also
how well the sample is grounded it's not
constructed your sample versus your
population
okay yeah so online uh Leah unmute
yourself feel free
oh thank you for the great talk uh so
from the talk I understood that you have
done great work in training the national
agriculture uh systems the nas systems
on how to collect the samples and send
to you the samples do you have any
program on training Champs or people you
know on how to use the data or you just
give the data to the National program
and then whatever they do the data it's
it's them it's their issue
yeah thanks Leah that's a great question
uh earlier you know we used to have
different modules we conduct you know
five days program where we uh you know
go from the baby team from the
genotyping space we help them in terms
of uh sampling and then the logistics
and then sending samples of those things
and then we also invite you know data
analytics team would help them training
in terms of for example uh you know
giving a demo on Flapjack or some of the
basic Galaxy tools to analyze the data
so and then later you know we have a
specialized team who are working in the
space of data analytics so some national
Partners you know they have their own
data analytics team who would uh you
know work with their data if some
national Partners you know uh if they
are having troubles in accessing or
analyzing data we will Loop them with
the you know rest of the maybe morning
is taking care of data analytics right
now we are also working with the data
analytics team to see how we can give
genotyping and data analysis of package
where any Partners can request you know
genotyping and data analysis we see
there is a lot of score we are working
on that currently you know we are
dealing that the case by case basis will
Mark as you know you mentioned it with
me but that was a really interesting
aspect we are dealing with
thank you just a follow-up question do
you charge for the data analytics or
software service
uh as I said you know we don't have a
structured way uh to help with the data
analytics currently uh we should stop
with the delivering the data and then
later connecting them with the right
research group who can help them you
know either uh providing a training on
data analytics or just helping with that
particular data set so we are doing the
case by case uh but not in a chargeable
amount we are just you know referring to
the different experts uh further you
know they are following International
partners and there are also specialized
group uh working on data analytics and
they were also working on
developing modules where you can do the
data analytics without you know doing
through programming and coding graphical
interface very simple
tools you can get your magnetic system
so that's a work and learn process it
will take some time between
okay thank you so much Leah for asking
the last question I think your last
question actually also alluded to our
next speaker
uh that's a Dockers
she will represent the breeding
analytics as logicals showed you there's
other surveys in data analytics and
there's a capacity building partner
building I think uh West University like
Cornell there could be a lot of
partnership in connecting the genotyping
the nutritional quality and then also
the downstream data analysis and the
completed Loop and we'll save that for
next Tuesday and for today let's give
one more round of applause to Raja Guru
thank you so much for running for
sharing and also this very informative
speech also thank you Susan for the nice
introduction and for everyone joining
online and also in the room okay good
afternoon now bye
thank you so much for the patient
listening I hope you enjoyed this
session and thanks darling thanks Susan
for the recording thank you so much
bye-bye thank you thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu